this is an unnecessarily rushed
explanation of the funniest video game
of all time Sam and Max hit the road
okay so seven max with the road is based
on this indie comic duo Sam he is a
canine detective he is a dog wearing
blue suit and Max who is a very violent
attaining rabbit so basically these guys
were invented for the black and white
comics world by Steve Purcell kind of
around the time when the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles Eastman and Laird not that
not the play made the scene of toys but
the actual look like of my comics right
so seven max you know endomorphic dog
and rabbit and they they they're from
the freelance police which I don't
really know what freelance police are I
think to solve crimes actually ruining
everything but somehow they got a video
game made out of them you could see for
sale the Creator the comic went to work
for Lucas arts and there the guys made
Monkey Island and maniac mansion all
those sorts of things and then he
convinced him to do 7x hit the road as a
point click adventure game now this was
incredibly funny so basically the entire
plot of this game is that Sam max
Bennett assignment because a big book on
missing from the County Fair and they go
down to the county fair and circus or
whatever in the Bigfoot is missing but
it turns out the Bigfoot actually ran
off with one of the giraffe neck girls
and there lately they go to they're
going to a Bigfoot convention held at
the hotel somewhere but then they
actually end up getting kidnapped by
this crazy country-western superstar
lots of Bigfoot to put in his sort of
like Graceland ish mansion so you've got
to break into the Graceland mansion you
got to get the Bigfoot other than the
Bigfoot goes to that to the Bigfoot
convention meanwhile okay all kinds of
stuff is happening then you better get
this information all the man who lives
inside of a tunnel of love rides you've
gotta use Mac c-max he's not only your
companion but he's also in vitam you can
indiscriminately use to solve problems
in this case 50
the water and electrifying them to shut
down the tunnel all right you talk your
ear off about but then he gives you the
things that you need so basically the
humor comes from the interactions
between Sam and Max and all the people
Lisa not people will like each other
these are a whole bunch of a-holes and
they all basically hate each other but
you have to continue on through the game
then then you end up getting Bigfoot
convention and figuring out all these
different things you need to do to make
sure that the the big big feet big foots
big feet can can you know so that their
race can live on which basically turns
out to bend the plot of the game the
entire time everything in it is Superman
drawings are very funny
the the country the crazy country nation
eyes pretty much seems a song about
white kidnaps to be Bigfoot's big feet
he sings a song about them anyway it's
really really funny and if you haven't
played it you absolutely have to salmon
exit the road funny skin involved